hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to off this
delightfully intriguing game now I just
finished cleaning out the barn and I
seem to have met some sort of a
Inquisition Emperor person Queen that
works with the Queen I don't know but
I'm getting sent back into the smoke
mines this game is interesting to say
the least more lights out
Oh oh don't worry my pure soul old me
through this
I found silver flesh oh hello that
startled me hello goodbye boom gone I'm
getting strong now okay so my conviction
will thwart me through this thought me
through is not exactly what I was hoping
for I hope you guys are enjoying this
game there's a lot of dialogue and a lot
of story to get through but that's what
makes these are feet oh hello I also
make these RPG horror games kind of are
not Horrigan this is not a [ __ ] game no
matter how strange this is it's what
makes this kind of interesting here so
hopefully you guys are enjoying it oh
there we go and I don't want people to
worry there are going oh god and I don't
want people to worry I'm not gonna skip
out any really important battles I'm
definitely not gonna overlook that so
anyway I just find a switch I flipped it
to off why would I need to do that maybe
to turn off the smoke so everyone on the
ship is gonna OH
piece of a batons me why am i finding so
much meat hang on I need to find exactly
what this meat does Oh
ah that's very nice so apparently I'm
gonna be shoving a lot of meat in my
face and it's gonna help me through this
game that's what it's trying to tell me
okay then
hey don't poke me there that is my
private circle no Brodie I'll do ah much
brighter now I hope I found everything
that I needed to I don't know if I may
have overlooked anything but preferably
not you're a weird one ain't you all
right what I'm saying is that the
average player doesn't need all these
complicated tedious dialogues there
should be more action and fuel questions
who are you
I'm Zachary the traditional items
merchants is necessary in every video
game I'll always find myself in places
you're going to visit before you arrive
enough blather I'm not one of those
protagonists you need to listen to for
hours so let me see the color of your
credits okay um Oh more meat oh my god
there's so many things I already have
that I already have that for that guy
who's the aura of justice well it looks
important Nicholas's tunic whoa oh I
need these yes no no no no go back there
we go nope no but yeah there we go yes
all right now I can make myself a little
bit better because I looked at this
before and if I go here or of justice
Nicholas's tunic yay I got stuff I got
things and stuff go I'm gonna be better
in combat I hope that no one is
expecting me to fail spectacularly
because I aim to succeed but hey you
come from from the smoke mines but play
how that's impossible
not a single lap where's air you you
can't uh faith guides my steps okay
chief my mission is to purify the mines
but it seems that there are phantoms
here in particularly numerous orbs the
specters where am I well uh
Oh more history good ah Oh yield phone
lines you're the plastic ministrations
of Shack Shehata
the northern part of the own one Wow
alright then what does any of that mean
our consists of filling in forms
afterwards we wrap them up in a string
and send them to the courier service
okay does anybody does anybody get
what's going on here they're they ship
the packages and in return we receive
parcels full of plastic I hope you guys
are filling in the other people that are
just as lost as I am in the comments
below because I don't know there are a
lot of liquid plastic and forms lakes in
the oceans what there's also solid
plastic used to make various objects
what are you gonna say it's the first of
the four elements is are you gonna say
oh you son of a [ __ ] how did I know
you're gonna say that it's an important
element you know plastic plastic smoked
metal all important the world would have
no boundaries people would walk and walk
without ever stopping you hunt specters
really yes
I'm purifying this zone the specters I
know where they come from they all come
from the Postal Service the Postal
Service that's where we sent out the
package forms so the problem is nobody
can remember which floor it's found on
that doesn't make any sense I'm going
I'm taking the lift Wow okay how about
no I'm never gonna get there ooh various
offices are you kidding me I'm gonna be
here forever and ever and ever I never
tried every single one on these
randomized ooh she's woo
I better go down to the basement I'll
get out of our way way before I purify
you yeah I'm gonna go to the ground
floor ah good reception well I might be
here forever
I probably don't need dogs every one of
them trying to find which one's actually
the one with information probably not pi
oh good I'm outside who cares where the
Postal Service is geez can't go that way
can't go this way does anybody want some
Abaddon's meat I got a lot of meat
filling up my pockets oh hello
the Queen's general has an office here
but his true house is in Alma well then
where was i before I've already been to
Damien have I been there Elson have I
cleared the smoke mines I don't even
know if I did that oh this is not where
I want to be how's the beginning I don't
need to be here and need to go back Oh
what about Pentel so with the farm
where's probably how good yes where the
hell am I now what are you doing to
those Oh God
Oh as soon as we extract everything from
the course well slice it up into pieces
and eat on me well I guess that's what
we normally do but ah yeah grouse
attracting the metal boulders from cows
isn't what I prefer but if I do my job
well maybe I'll get transferred to Alma
maybe you've been lied to it's half a
cow good Oh
squishy goodness Oh delightful
thank you so much so what I need to do
is I need to find the post office but to
do that I need to find which floor it's
actually on which could be a problem
considering I don't know what the hell
I'm going in life
yeah I got another bill oh hi are you
gonna tell me where the post office is
who matters brother beans where are the
other drugs going well the other drugs
going hey I did it I still don't know
what that switch did but I found another
ghost tegu whoa wait a minute I know
what I'm doing here
I didn't oh man these guys died quick
these days I guess that's good means I
won't be here forever warlock tickets
Pollock tickets I must be the luckiest
son of a [ __ ]
oh whoa one hit want it Kalon the best
beside the roof I've been to the roof
yet it's obviously a place I need to go
hello hi my friends sounds you again you
want to sided Lee everywhere one could
believe that you are following me
nonetheless your steps have not deceive
you you are here in lu lu that concern
lee use sacred blows with your holy bat
perhaps you already aware of this but
it's piers that the story housing the
postal service is overrun by ectoplasm
it would probably be wise to find the
story with the intangible creatures both
days in order to dispatch them but could
it be that the task is too difficult for
your narrow mind in that case I may be
able to provide you with some advice
some help would be welcome open widely
your ears and listen for I will not
repeat this twice not even in the midst
of the most pathetic supplication in one
of the four rooms on the ground floor
all the employees seem to be trained to
a particular set of instructions
additionally if there was a choice to be
made
I would prefer the lower case over the
upper case that is all well then aren't
you just too sassy slinging Slough well
you take your pussy-wussy cat advice
and yeah okay so the lower case is
obviously meaning oh hello the lower
case obviously means the stamps as
opposed to the forms so I need to be
looking at the stamps come on give you
stamps
oh hello ah ah ten to five eight huh
it's dodging ah ten to five eight here
we go right so where we need the girl I
probably should have guessed that a
while ago I should have paid attention
huh
but apparently not ah Postal Service and
no one here eh
no underneath my divine power of justice
yea ye shall find them to bow game
everyone my divine justice needs all
hello well you i'm the batter no one
even asked me that but i'ma say it
anyway we're the Phantom's I'm I'm very
afraid happy wha bow your head I'll help
you straight to hell
Goodell O'Neal ooh down here good you
were purified
he was obviously infested was maybe
maybe his suit has taken control of his
brain what strange very strange indeed
god this reminds me of earthbound again
like that purple area the cult first
version they are six feet under wrapped
in hot metal and liquid plastic cool gay
what feel under that doesn't make any
sense
start making sons game before I slug you
with my back remember uh something
strange they are eight they have long
beards they watch what is happening from
their high silver spheres so was eight
and six from the first one so man let me
go back I need to look make sure there
wasn't a number number oh not you again
oh you weirdo rat Oh creatures that's
the first time I'm funny so I won't do
it Otto you should feel honored I'm gone
yeah that's right get out of here
purified you crap out of you okay so I
need to go back and just double check
that this is actually six feet under ok
hot metal plastic okay hot hm and liquid
plastic lick plastic hot em lick blessed
okay got it I'm in it to win it I'm all
about this oh hey my little guy got it
got a level up oh man that guy needs a
name what is he big circle berry big
sphere berry big circle bear okay eight
long beards okay eight long beards long
B's long beards hi silver okay so we got
hot em lick P long B and hi ass got it
nailing it I got it ah
so well what do we have in 4,000 okay
Eric three four seven [ __ ]
oh so my stage they are four in the
fourth
Oh video each one pretty relevant so one
Ella and respect crystals respect crisps
respect Chris or else
Oh freakin weirdos good please leave me
alone I'm trying to finish this game
this is gonna be a bit of a problem
ain't it the bull something strange a
soul big instant whose mandibles spit
meat okay third big ants mandible Oh
spit me okay spit me and begins got it
I'm ready I'm so in it I'm so with it
I'm so happening
ah v v v v like hand long smoke okay go
last but two secret got it ready to roll
bring it on the access to secret left is
up forbidden didn't did I say secret
oh I must pass
I think that's an impossible unless you
have the code ah crap
six to eight long beards high silver
three big insects spit me don't know
what that is four four I think it's oh
whoops no no no no four four five five
like a hand six but - okay is this is
one was it just one insect one big
insect that was what I said right hey
the code is exactly great oh wow yeah he
was ambassador today oh I see hello
prepare to die that exact thing that you
didn't want to happen it's happening now
right now good job
you've been purified let me past
congratulations
I'm guys Alma it will be nice you're
also going to be dead good job
Lu floor question the directors of the
story I'm pretty quite a bit oh hello
miserable morons piss off this is my
zone you ain't got the right to bear get
out of my sight you phantasms of [ __ ]
you need to watch your body mouth young
man but not her you it's you you're the
source of all my troubles
the ectoplasmic Lord who's been eyeing
my beloved zone what do you want why
have you decided to be a pain in the ass
and I've dedicated my whole life to this
place you've got no right to ruin it
with your damned ghosts shove off why do
I think you're British you're mistaken
I'm not a phantom I'm a bureau fire I've
come to purge the world of these
ectoplasmic beings how dare you respond
and I'll do you imagine that I just put
up with a [ __ ] listen good I'll make
this simple get out of here and take
your goddamn specs with you or I'm going
to kill you
I'll bet clear enough for you if I see
you again you're dead you're dead me hey
don't run away from me the tramway can
now stop in Alma what you just abandon
your zone after all that JibJab about
talking about how great your zone one's
you're just up and left it way to go
there you're a shining example to all
your employees uh what is there another
area that in an explorer what's going on
here wait a minute whoa hang on I need
to find this out okay I don't I don't
think that's a very the area of four I
think was also the other part over there
I'm pretty sure mmm
okay got it
yes am I good did I did it it did I done
it did I do good did I win I think I won
I think I may have progressed to where I
was supposed to be but I'm not entirely
sure hello I need to go to Alma can I go
- I can go - um Alma was the creepy
little girl from fear I wonder if
there's gonna be something to fear here
only my fists of justice I don't have
the right to let anyone bet let's answer
some questions later whoo take a closer
look yes hello I will gladly do this I
got you
so I need to observe you huh what am I
supposed to be observing oh god do I
need to write some of this stuff down
again
I need more paper June 3
1 1 so 18 3 11 18 311
um I'll answer your questions the second
came from ditch Riesling I don't know
ah Lourdes the Holy Trinity is made up
of noted on birds beard in the 60 mm how
many threes are there in June Oh who's
gonna take me well I'll be right guys
one one second
just something bolstered her that's some
talent jingle damn [ __ ] I'm gonna
write down all the two routes along
memorizing her looked herbal Dermer
gonna gobble gooble goo oh ok so ii came
from Jerusalem so goddamn I need to like
copy those down and write them like oh I
can just copy and oh I can screenshot
him and maybe one second I'm gonna
figure this out
third from Orta third from Horta ok the
Holy Trinity I got it I got all the I
took pictures of them I put them over
hearing on the I didn't even read the
goddamn question god damn it what how do
you even understand what you're trying
to ask me it doesn't say anything on
there I know whatever roses notre-dame
Oh God when did Notre Dame affair when
de notre-dame appear Notre Dame appear
right oh ah oh I was right I guess right
all right and this one um oh boy
hang on one second four five six seven
eight one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
22 if you got okay 22 if you got the one
in the center cereal Kevin and hey Koko
I wanted to answer some stupid-ass
question Oh
surreal Kevin Jonas hey oh man's is a
crotch
ha oh come on you dick if you turn the
month March upside down what to tinton
number what huh okay March 11 oh damn
you're gonna make me go through it all
again
11 ah but hang on everybody hang on uh
Schramm what number will that be
what the hell by looking at oh wait a
minute oh there's a wall there's a
number in the thing there's a number in
the thing 87 wait a minute there's a
number in there there's a number in
there there's a number inside it 87
right okay
I'm gonna beat your quiz hi make me get
read to it huh yeah suck on that yo okay
oh you you upset that I beat your stupid
quiz and now you're gonna fight me well
take my auto-attacks
branch good right take your stupid quiz
and shove it up your bum bum bum bum bum
bum bum my knees are all dirty el now
get out of my way you phantasm all
phantasms must be purified to tell you
you yeah I'm here to say day Don where I
said it let me pass hey Don yeah yeah
yes of course
oh god more lessons on the weird world
you live in
you're here at the meat fountains of
Omaha the meat found oh okay the first
okay pounds of meat just glorious meat
everywhere meat
everyone did the lie to eat here meat
flows freely continually filling these
immense metal pools you see before you
the children they play with the meat all
day everyone gets to eat as much meat as
they would like they shove it in their
mouths our work consists of pouring this
meat in the bottles before the mountains
overflow oh good Glick with me yay the
meat is then immediately delivered to
the only other zone from zone 1 on it is
one of the basic elements that's the
first of four elements meat is very
important and it's nutritious part of
your everyday breakfast meat for
breakfast no its reasons meat cereal
because without meat people would have
nothing to eat they would die of
starvation one after another good yes
master dana has an office in the center
of the fountains but now but nobody has
ever found it generally speaking master
date on seems to only appear when
necessary well uh there I guess dr. Todd
who are you anyway I've come to liberate
the world of malignant oh really
that sounds good well then can you
liberate me oh how such a creepy way to
put that cheese fine I'll liberate you
from your weird head and your weird pets
okay bye
perhaps you'll get better now okay
probably not kid oh and remember guys
I'm never gonna skip a battle that I
deem important so hopefully you guys
don't have to worry about that
I will manually fight every important
bath hello Makka Parra and good Jay
perhaps you have some fair credits color
a brass that looks good out of that i
christen symbol that is bettering my
cool we're doing even better now we're
doing so much better
we're gonna deal so much damage not that
anything's been particularly tough are
those rivers of blood or meat either way
just delightful please let me work no
I'm gonna smash you in the face with my
baton you don't look so good there um
I'm having fun dancing maybe all these
battles is just gonna be a mark of our
dance competition with myself
Oh level 5 achieved yeah I've never been
ill and yet you did good job but doll
Orica was what's up Adele oh oh that's a
poodle oh oh oh it's all squishy why is
it all scuzzy Oh loves Kissin oh that's
all squishy okay I get it I need to
write more stuff down all right I don't
need to tell me twice geez who's up
squishing 1/4 to 900 meaty Oh what are
you
I'll fight you I'll fight you myself I
don't need anybody else Oh
yeah able to swing the village until you
follow God's you are a creepy thing
where are you coming out of anyway
what's not a weird meet pool pocket are
you guys thanks for smiling at me you
weirdo ah get some poison fam bunch
there we go I won now I never have to do
that myself again Oh
slap slap it's all slappy ass meat ah ah
so Rudy why for two goddamn it with your
slappy slaps table at ah let me out see
Scott son of a [ __ ] I don't want to be
burnt I'm not gonna burnt you I'm gonna
hit you in the face with my back even
though your face is way up there I'm
still gonna hit it it's a very long back
well crap good well done well said
everybody well said dude yeah I called
the paddle oh not that I needed it
anyway hey it's good me I need it for
dialogue you don't want to be a phantom
too bad you already are what's happening
to me you're dying get over it where's
this Padano gonna come up
oh good glad that happened where's that
potala leaving oh oh it's part of the
puzzle okay I got it
Oh hit it hit the thing head it just hit
this stupid thing oh it's not working
now huh is back okay it's backwards no
okay for one oh wow for
9:8 okay I got it now
I think I don't have all the necessary
information there might be another area
that I need because apparently these
other numbers I tried all of them don't
work so give me a Padano
but no longer productive enough well
maybe if you weren't really if your
heads weren't in the clouds maybe they
need have some and I got it with my
myself apparently I'm not working who's
going to do but you're not productive
enough so gotta okay so call Padano so
I'm assuming that there's gonna be a new
set of numbers ah here we go so it was
four nine eight two six five but the six
is highlighted so I'm assuming that's
the right number so six five 600 you
weirdos good Eddie
Wow
nice hit there onion ring onion ring
Oliver that's what I would call you
onion ring all of our onion ring Oliver
you did your most adorable freakishly
weird circle I've ever seen in my life I
need ring Oliver everyone's gonna love
you wait a minute was only two numbers
well am I supposed to get there was only
two numbers a silver flesh and a meat
river sign over here no take it off
oh so meaty
really uh no seven and eight I got you
seven and eight so I'm assuming that six
five seven eight does this go anywhere
oh no it doesn't god damn it okay it's
seven nine eight see okay I got it
I got the whole cold I got it all I'm
gonna save again holy hell okay so
anyway I'm still all out of time for
this episode remember I'm trying to do
30-minute episodes here I don't know how
long it's gonna be after I try to trim
up the battle's a bit but either way I
really hope you're enjoying this game
guys because I am absolutely intrigued
by what's coming next and I honestly
have
no idea what's happening in this game or
why but I'm on a quest for purification
and nothing shall stand in my way I hope
I'm making good progress for you guys so
thank you all so much for watching let
me know what you think is happening in
the game right now and it comes below
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye this is like a bad idea
and then there was a war and everyone
died except for the Americans of course